how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel
and everything relating to the mcu and
today we have a very special video as i
have an
exclusive report lately there's been a
lot of talk about
captain marvel 2 and a lot of characters
possibly making their mcu debut
including some x-men characters many of
you may have heard the report that
marvel studios is talking about rogue
making her appearance in captain marvel
2
as the villain well today we have found
out a little bit more about this story
what marvel studios is planning and
other characters that are going to be in
the film as well
including spider-man the possibility of
nova making his debut
as well and another new super villain
all of which we're going to break down
and talk about how marvel studios is
planning to do all of this in captain
marvel 2. we'll break it down in this
video
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest mcu news and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a hawkeye
funko pop and if you like g-fuel or are
looking for an
alternative healthy energy drink be sure
to use code cosmic gfuel.com for a
discount
so as i mentioned this is an exclusive
report given to me by mikey sutton who
originally broke
the rogue in captain marvel 2 news and
here's the new scoop directly from mikey
sutton himself
the marvel cinematic universe is like a
galactic map that threads
one world with another everything has a
purpose each scene
every line they will all later paint the
big picture it's no coincidence that the
scrolls appeared in both the captain
marvel and spider-man far from home
films
according to mikey sutton sources all
three are set to form captain marvel 2.
it was on september of 2019 that mikey
scooped on the lords of the long box
that captain marvel 2
would feature varanke as the main
villain in a loose adaptation of
the secret invasion and now he's learned
that the plans for captain marvel 2 are
evolving with secret invasion
remaining its core focus after the roots
of secret invasion are planted on disney
plus
captain marvel will be battling more
than just one scroll
in her sequel in fact more than a scroll
but a
super scroll however it has been
revealed to mikey sutton that it won't
be the super scroll with the fantastic
force powers
rather it's going to be a super scroll
with the abilities
of spider-man and thus marvel studios
will pay homage to marvel team-up number
62
wearing carol danvers back then miss
marvel at the time and spider-man
collaborated to fight the super scroll
mcu solo movies have gotten bigger with
each successor and captain marvel 2
fits into that mold by having spider-man
guest star
and mikey sutton also leaked back in
september of 2019 that marvel studios
wanted
nova to debut in captain marvel 2 as
well
and based off of what he has heard he
says that this could either be
a brief introductory appearance or if
the super scroll has taken spider-man's
powers
nova could provide a much needed power
boost
and as far as rogue is concerned there
is still talk about her making her
mcu debut in captain marvel 2 but
instead of being the main
villain of captain marvel 2 super scroll
will be the main villain and
rogue will appear at the end making a
cameo as a villain and setting up the
third movie with miss marvel appearing
in captain marvel 3 as well
so as you can see here lots of really
big plans not only for captain marvel 2
but also for captain marvel
3. the super scroll is somebody that we
thought was going to make an appearance
in captain marvel because we knew that
the scroll were going to play a pretty
big part
now what's really interesting about what
they did in the first captain marvel is
that they made the scroll
good and we did see them again in
spider-man far from home in the
post-credits scene
linking spider-man and captain marvel
but this came as a really big surprise
because in the comics the scroll
aren't good they're far from it they're
actually bad and although they're
portrayed as good
in the mcu right now there are
definitely going to be some bad scroll
and one of those is going to be the
super scroll now in the comics the super
scroll has the abilities of
all of the fantastic four members put
together that's why he's the super
skrull
but we know that marvel does not adapt
100
the comics into the marvel cinematic
universe they just take
tidbits from here and there so according
to mikey the new super scroll that's
coming
to the mcu is going to have the powers
of spider-man now when you combine this
with his already superhuman strength
speed and agility not to mention
shape-shifting abilities he could
definitely be a big
problem especially if he posed as
spider-man
and the thing is is that we've already
seen some of this kind of take place
in spider-man fire from home who we
thought was nick fury and maria hill the
whole entire movie turned out to be
talos and his wife
so we've already seen just how dangerous
the scroll can be now granted they were
doing this to help nick fury and shield
in spider-man far from home but their
powers and abilities could just as
easily be used to manipulate some of the
heroes and that's what secret invasion
is about
so although there are good scroll bad
scroll definitely exist and it sounds
like they're coming to invade earth
but this does set up something really
and truly awesome
captain marvel and spider-man together
and this is actually going to be
a very important movie as far as the
future of the mcu is concerned and the
new
avengers and it looks like what's going
to unite spider-man and captain marvel
is going to be the scroll just like
mikey says in marvel team up number 62.
now when marvel team up number 62
spider-man starts off by fighting the
super scroll himself and doesn't really
end up defeating him he has a really
hard time battling the super scroll but
manages to escape
then the super scroll goes and attacks
captain marvel who was
at the time miss marvel and then captain
marvel and spider-man would go on to
take on the super scroll now right now
in the marvel cinematic universe the
scroll have had contact with two
superheroes and that is captain marvel
and spider-man in the comics the super
scroll is given the abilities of all of
the fantastic four members and then sent
to earth to defeat the fantastic four
and the plan was that once he defeated
the fantastic four
the scroll would invade and considering
the fact that mikey says that captain
marvel 2 is still
going to be based on the secret invasion
storyline this is most likely what's
going to happen in captain marvel 2.
although instead of the scroll giving
one of their scroll who would become the
super scroll
all of the powers of the fantastic four
they'll give him the powers
of spider-man he'll then come to earth
and try to defeat the two heroes that
they know
exist captain marvel and spider-man
forcing them to team up but what's
really exciting
is is that this is going to be the first
time that we see the two
new leaders of the future new avengers
team fighting together we've heard
plenty of times from marvel themselves
that captain marvel
and spider-man are going to be leading
the avengers they're essentially going
to be like iron man and captain america
so captain marvel 2 may be when the new
avengers start to be
established especially if you consider
the fact that nova could possibly be
making his marvel cinematic universe
debut in captain marvel 2
as well now if you think about it this
is actually quite an
easy setup for nova to appear in captain
marvel 2. if you take the events of
avengers infinity war and avengers end
game in the events of the first captain
marvel and you put them together it kind
of makes sense that nova would actually
seek out captain marvel at the end of
captain marvel carol danvers sets out to
basically help the rest of the universe
and then in avengers in-game when she's
talking to the rest of the avengers
black widow
nebula roadie rocket okoye rocket asks
her when she's going to be back and she
says that she's helping a lot of other
planets and a lot of other people in the
universe and not to mention when roadie
asked her where she's been the entire
time
she told him that there was a lot of
other people out there in the universe
that unfortunately didn't have the
avengers
now here she could specifically be
talking about zandar because in avengers
infinity war
thanos decimated it and nova could have
been the only person left that would
mean he would inherit the full
nova force and him and captain marvel
could have met and we know that a script
was written for avengers in-game which
originally included
nova coming to earth to warn the
avengers about thanos instead of the
hulk
what was originally going to happen is
that xandar gets decimated and there's
only one survivor
nova we were actually going to see
thanos decimate zandar and then nova go
to earth
but unfortunately we didn't see that we
only heard about it but zandar
is destroyed and nova is going to need a
place to live and since he most likely
knows captain marvel because she's made
her way around the universe his plan may
be to go to earth
kevin feige for years now has said that
they do have plans to introduce nova
into the marvel cinematic universe over
the years he's been asked several times
and every time he's been asked he says
yes there are plans not to mention
recently there have been
several reports that say nova is in fact
coming and that it's confirmed however
they have not said when but according to
mikey sutton it's going to be in captain
marvel 2 and it would fit in with the
story and the continuity of the mcu
pretty well and then the last awesome
part of this report is the fact that
rogue
could be appearing at the end to be set
up as the main villain of captain marvel
3.
captain marvel was a huge success
captain marvel 2 will most likely be a
huge one as well
and it's pretty much a guarantee that
we'll get a captain marvel 3 and
rogue is a classic captain marvel
villain but perhaps
rogue since her abilities are to
basically take other people's abilities
is somehow connected to the super scroll
she could be the villain
behind the super scroll especially if
you consider the fact that a lot of the
scroll are actually good there are
probably some skrull who are
a little bit bitter about everything
that happened and since rogue will be a
villain
she could team up and kind of stir the
pot with the skrull who are angry and
give the super scroll powers
right now it's shrouded in mystery but
it sounds like captain marvel 2 is
shaping up to be
an excellent movie already we have
captain marvel spider-man
the super scroll nova and then rogue so
a lot of exciting things coming to the
marvel cinematic universe
including a lot of exciting new
characters so let me know what you think
about this report in the comments down
below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe for more mcu related content
and so you don't miss out on any of the
news
thanks again to mikey sutton for this
exclusive report for live updates you
can always follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof